what up space fame goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest updates
in the one piece story
today we got some insane moments both
good and very
tragic as well so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you do enjoy seeing
one piece reviews
on the channel and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you can do is
smash
that like button and share this video
with your nakama if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial
ring that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos
make this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist where i got
videos about the supernova
the warlords the yonko and much much
more link in the description now without
further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all we
start this chapter with the contrasting
fire festival happening in the flower
capital while the war
and fight we've been following for so
many chapters continues to rage on here
people are celebrating the fire festival
which only happens once a year this is a
very interesting segment
in my opinion we are told that this is
the only prosperous place
in the whole of lano and that behind the
smiles lie
feelings of oppression and fear that
they've lived with
up to now we are told that they are
alive only because
of their belief that someday the samurai
of the kozuki family
will help save their homeland this is a
very powerful moment
showing the potential importance of hope
in life the one thing keeping them going
despite the horrible conditions of
living under orochi and kaido all these
decades
is that they might be saved from them
someday
and odin is this symbol for them that is
how important a symbol
or the example set by a great human can
be
it could literally mean the difference
between life and death for people
as the narrator says everyone was using
the legend of odin
and his samurai as a way of supporting
their hearts even though
they thought it was probably not gonna
happen but we
as the readers got special info and we
know this exact
battle that they were hoping for is
raging with the nine red scabbards
luffy and the rest but for the people of
wano the idea is still some implausible
dream
nonetheless an important one though
people wonder about how nice it would be
if today never ended since the festival
is special and as one mentioned
it's the only time of year that they can
drink alcohol and some straight-up break
into tears
wishing that kaido didn't have orochi's
back although as far as we
the readers know up to this point orochi
is dead unless his devil fruit powers
somehow let him survive
getting his head cut off but moments
like this in anime and manga help us
appreciate what we have in our own lives
chances are if you're watching this
video you aren't limited to celebrating
or
if you're old enough drinking alcohol
once a year and you probably aren't
starving as much as much of the people
of wano are
as a result these kinds of moments also
remind us to be thankful in our real
lives for what we
do have even as we continue to hope that
luffy beats kaido and
in so doing ends wano's suffering then
we have quite the coincidence
one drunk dude suggests what if the
battle with the kozuki family is
happening right now at this very moment
and they gathered samurai from all over
the world to fight by their side
obviously he didn't mention pirates but
this is pretty much what's happening
right now
another mentions how orochi might have
been cut down and kaido may be next
and onigashima is in a frenzy and that's
exactly what appears to be happening too
last time we saw kaido the scabbard
seemed to reopen his odin wound
and he definitely seemed to be on the
defensive furthermore onigashima is
definitely in a frenzy with multiple
fights going
on at the same time but these guys don't
actually
know that to be the case so one drunk
odin lookalike
mentions enthusiastically to keep the
stories coming because today
they can dream as much as they want not
knowing that their dream is pretty much
a reality on origami
right now people are so grateful because
for today at least they can have great
tasting water some clean air
and that no one will get killed and even
though many people would expect that to
just happen every day
for these people those criteria aren't
met every day and they're not even
complaining about that
rather they're celebrating because they
get one day with these pretty basic
human conditions being met
it makes you appreciate these characters
and also look at your own life and at
how you
may be taking many things for granted
anyways these people continue to
celebrate their small victory of having
the fire festival despite how difficult
their lives can be
we then return to onigashima people are
running and we see an
ice demon to zorro's shock drake lets us
know that it's the plague
and thus all star queen is behind it
like a virus
it spreads from person to person turning
the infected person into a kind of ice
demon
queen wants to close the doors to the
towers and have everyone on this floor
succumb to this plague
including his own guys pretty beastly
behavior right there
but not too surprising it makes sense
that queen the plague
would have access to something like this
we then catch up to luffy and sanji
sanji is trying to keep luffy from
getting involved in fights so that he
can conserve his energy for kaido
it's pretty hilarious watching them
argue about how it will take sanji 10
seconds to clear the opponents while it
will take only 3 seconds if luffy helps
him and then as they argue
jinbei takes out the headliner briscola
a gorilla smile user with one punch
clearing the way
jinbe then says he'll clear the rest of
the way too and both sanji
and luffy should conserve their strength
i also love how excited luffy gets when
he sees jimbei
screaming out his name like we probably
did in our minds when we saw him
sanji gets all upset since he's the one
that wants to escort luffy
which is interesting because jinbei is
sort of disrupting
sanji's place in the crew as a member of
the monster trio the monster trio used
to be luffy zorro and sanji the three
strongest of the crew but jinbe coming
in arguably messes with sanji's position
so this is the kind of meta moment we
see in this interaction
still though it's more comedic and
nothing too serious and they're gonna
work together and try to accomplish the
impossible
to keep luffy from jumping into fights
and the whole thing is pretty hilarious
because if they let their guard down for
one second
even to talk or argue luffy will just
get caught in a fight again
and of course jinbei the former warlord
is as cool as ever comfortable in his
position
and strength and not needing to prove
anything then we jump to shinobu
momonosuke and yamato bao huang
lets king know where they are king is
dark and strategic
suggesting to everyone that they kill
momonosuke since then the rebellion for
the revival of the kozuki family would
fall apart
since the samurai would no longer have a
horse in the race to fight for
it would devastate morale and king knows
this kill the symbol and you'll probably
kill their hope
and at that point the majority of the
samurai will quite possibly give up
king even says to bring him omonosuke's
head it's almost scary how calm
and machiavellian he is about this whole
thing although he's not a good guy
you gotta respect king as a good
antagonist sasuke is the one who finds
momo first
and has his men fire at them again why
didn't dengiro kill this dude
when he had the chance now that decision
is already coming back to haunt them
poor shinobu uses herself as a shield
protecting momo
it's enough to bring one to tears and
just as it looks
like it's all over and shinobu and momo
are about to be killed yamato comes to
the rescue
and this is the turn we needed now momo
will no longer fear yamato
as an enemy since she just saved his
life and shinobu
and by the way props are manly momo who
didn't run
when shinobu told him to saying a shogun
wouldn't run away
sasaki is amused to see yamato but
yamato is determined
saying in the name of the kozuki family
she's participating in this
war epic moment for all three of them
shinobu momo and yamato and then we jump
back to the insane cliffhanger we got
last chapter
kaido on the ground his odin wound
bleeding and red scabbard standing over
his seemingly inanimate body
obviously the red scabbards are too
smart to think this is already over
they know they gotta finish him off
quick until his head is off his body
it ain't over but of course before they
can finish him off
once and for all kaido comes too and
he's not begging for life or anything
he just comments on the tenacity of the
red scabbards kaido says for a moment he
felt like he saw kozuki odin
and he even says that he wouldn't have
mind if they killed him because as we
know
he tried to take his own life plenty of
times and we get important info here he
says that when his wound aches he's
reminded of it and we get a flashback to
when he only beat odin because kurozumi
higurashi
used her clone clone fruit to trick odin
into thinking that momo
was taken hostage kaido then took
advantage of the distraction
to defeat him i've been emphasizing this
for a while
and how kaido probably felt guilty about
winning in this way
after all he even had kurozumi higurashi
killed for it but he was still a coward
he didn't release odin and give him a
fair fight
afterwards no he proceeded to execute
him and that lack of integrity and that
cowardice especially conscious to odin's
honor and courage
haunts kaido to this day for him odin
and the wound odin gave him are
symbols of his own shortcomings so it
makes sense that odin's memory
would make him unstable and more prone
to injury
however kaido mentions that despite all
of this these guys meaning the red
scabbars
are not odin and that there will never
be a samurai as monstrous as odin again
i have to admit the first thing i
thought of when i read this was zorro he
definitely has a samurai thing going on
and i believe he will be the strongest
swordsman ever by the end of the series
so yeah perhaps zoro really will have a
role to play
against kaido who appears to be more
affected by sword wounds
than anything else however for now kaido
just says that the cuts of the red
scabbers are too
shallow and with only this level of
strength they won't even be able to open
up his old wound properly
he calls him too weak and launches wind
slashes from his mouth
such a simple move for him and by
launching this move he sends the red
scabbards in an uproar
the twist has finally happened and at
the very least
kiku has been devastatingly wounded it
appears that an
entire arm is off at least and the
slashes are so strong that they cut
kiku's sword like it was nothing
kiku's eyes are white as if it might
really be the end
and this shocks the red scabbards as it
may shock us
even though i've been saying that the
turnaround would happen it was only a
matter of time
obviously you can't just wipe out a
yonko without any casualties
and i did think we'd get one or even
more red scabbard deaths
because they came ready for it and
attempting to take down the strongest
creature in the world
will definitely lead to sacrifices let
me know if you think kiku is gonna
survive
or if this is the end let me also know
what you thought of this chapter and
what you expect to happen in the next
one kaido definitely turned the tone
around by 180 degrees
he flexed on them by saying he wishes
they could defeat him
but they're just too weak and with that
we have entered the difficult portion of
this fight
up to now i was mentioning it felt like
we were cruising through it
and things seemed to be going too well
well now the reality of the situation
has begun to catch up with everybody
and i wouldn't be surprised if this is
just the beginning of a much
much more brutal counter-attack from
kaido and although we don't want to see
our guys hurt
this is a yonko we're talking about and
we've yet to see him fight here in his
humanoid and possibly hybrid form
which are arguably much stronger so we
gotta be expecting tragic moments to
come
we can't expect that to be avoided at
this point but that is it for this
chapter
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep the one piece reviews coming on
this channel
the best thing you can do is smash that
like button and share this video with
your nakama
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
make this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out our
growing one piece playlist where i got
videos about the supernova
the warlords the yonko and much much
more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who help make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by
lord twigo himself alpha sigma and liam
thompson
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans
in grata the world acquire respect potay
hepa jonathan king rethuan dei aura
red haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones ken mono admirath
and christopher torley and are pro hero
to your patrons the one and only
gilgamesh who's the current most donated
overall champion of the world
nothing but a fan steelers anatoly
kazatsuki cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica calefon
alicia actor hinokami and water
bonnie parks florian joanne garcia mick
sheamus
deadly saint and highschool dxd73
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com anime uproar
and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
animeopro
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you